Welcome to the DDPS seminar. Everyone, Before we
introduce our invited speaker, let's go over some
rules and logistics. First, please mute yourself
during the talk, but if you have questions,
you can unmute and ask questions, or use chat
room to post your questions so that we can
address them in Q and A session at the end second,
today's DDPS seminar is open to external audience,
therefore no classified this question is
allowed. So please watch out. Finally,
the talk today will be recorded and uploaded
in our YouTube channel. That's about it now.
Let me briefly introduce our speaker today.
It is an honor to host Dr Marius jainhofer,
who received his PhD from the University
of Freiburg, Germany, where he researched
multi physics models for bone growth under
the supervision of Professor Patrick donde
He then served as a postdoctoral research fellow
at similar research laboratory in Oslo Norway,
focusing on scientific machine learning
with Professor Kent Andra model. Currently,
he is a researcher at the University Hospital
Freiburg, specializing in AI for healthcare.
His ongoing research interests include error
analysis and optimization of neural network
based methods for solving partial differential
equations. Today, Marius will talk about
infinite dimensional optimization for scientific
machine learning. I'm sure we are going to hear a
wonderful talk before I pass the button to Marius,
as a traditional tradition to the DDPS seminar,
let me ask a somewhat informal question so that
we can we we know something, something, something
about Marius somewhat out of The technical
reason so I happen to know you are very keen
to Gita playing, if you can share your favorite
piece, favorite music you would like to play?
Oh, that's that's a difficult
question. It changes. Yes. Well,
let's just go with the classics, which is
stairway to happen by Led Zeppelin, okay, um,
non GitHub, as a non guitar
player, I never heard of that.
Oh, you can, you can. It's a good
one. You can, you can. Check it out.
Okay, I will definitely check it out.
Well, thank you. The stage is yours. Thank
you. Thank you for the nice introduction, and
let's get started. So today I'll talk about
optimization for scientific machine learning.
And talk will be structured in roughly two parts
first, and that's the specialty. Sort of of our
approach is the function space perspective on the
optimization for siml problem problems. And what
I will propose to you is these kind of problems
to adopt an infinite dimensional viewpoint or
continuous viewpoint, leaving out the answers
class. And then develop optimizers, or choose
optimizers based on the infinite the properties
on the on the function space level, and then
discretize in a certain way that guarantees you
that you mimic the function space dynamic. And
with this principle in mind, we'll see how we
can design new algorithms and also understand
existing ones from that perspective. And then
in the next step, with the after designing these
optimization methods, we'll have a look into how
you can scale them to large scale neural networks.
We'll do that with one specific strategy where we
use the Chronicle structure of the linear layer
Jacobians in the neural networks. The talk is
mainly based on these two papers I've linked
here below one position paper this year's ICML,
and then a recent one which is related to the
second part, which is about the Kronecker factor
approximation. So let's dive in. Let's start
with the function space optimization. And let's
clarify, sort of what kind of problems I want to
talk about. I said scientific machine learning.
And for me, or at least for this talk, mainly
what I have in mind is operator learning. I. But
also methods for srodingers equation, the electron
Schrodinger equation, with that network ansatz can
be physics and formula networks, formulations of
partial differential equations or inverse problems
could be deep red, so rational formulations,
essentially anything that involves PDE terms
in the loss function and neural networks, the
methods will be well suited for all of them.
And one observation, so the starting point also
for our work in this direction is that as soon
as you introduce PDEs to objective functions, the
neural network training gets more difficult. Let
me give you an illustration of that statement that
optimization and sign melt can be quite hard. I
have two pictures here for you. Details are not
so important. Let's look at the first one here.
I've taken this from a recent paper, the forward
laplacian paper. So in this paper, they solve the
many electron Schrodinger equation. When I what
I want to stress here is the sheer amount of GPU
hours that I used for single solve. It is in the
in the 1000s, almost towards 10,000 GPU hours for
single problem. And then the other paper is a
very simple problem. It's just a two dimensional,
awesome equation. And with a smooth solution,
you formulate it and use the pin formulation,
and you optimize green is just full batch
gradient descent, where and red is Adam,
and you see huge amount of iterations and you see
stagnating errors. So what we are going to do here
is to abandon first order optimization and look
into the structure on the infinite dimensional
spaces. We want to exploit the geometry that is
induced by the PDE operators to this to design
smarter algorithms. And I have an informal road
map here for you how to do that. I call it first
optimized and discretized. So we are given a syml
problem, and later also under Network answers. And
the first thing we need to do is think about
the continuous formulation. So we need to
formulate a minimization problem. Let's say it's
a minimization problem. It could be saddle points,
route finding, whatever. So it's a minimization
problem in a Hilbert space age. That's a function
space here. So E the energy, that's what we
want to minimize. So we need clarity about
how that should look like. And then after we
formulated a problem, we'll have a look in what
are the properties of E right? And here it's left
abstract. There is no properties assumed. But in
a practical application, it will have properties.
And based on these properties on function space,
we'll decide for an appropriate algorithm set,
an appropriate iterative algorithm in function
space. What I mean by that is you update your
current iterate by a direction, and you step
until you're happy with it, right? But remember,
this is in function space. This is nothing you
can you can practically do and to get something
back, which is with which you can do in practice,
which you can do on your machine, then you need
to discretize. But notice, this is the last step
and discretization here. What I propose is to
project the update direction. This would be
decay on the tension space of your neural network
answers, or on whatever your answer is. If it's
not neural networks, it's also fine. So let's,
let us put that, make that concrete with a very,
very simple example that the example is as simple
as it can possibly be arguably. So suppose we
want to solve Poissons equation on some domain
omega. We have some forcing data. We have some
boundary conditions. That's the starting point.
Then I reformulate the equation, in this case
as a minimization problem. I've chosen here the
simplest one. This would be physics and formula,
networks formulation. But of course you
could choose a very variational formulation,
or you could formulate it as a root finding
problem. But let's stick with this. So I've chosen
here the hill. Which space is h2 this is how it
looks. No unsat class, no, nothing, just the pure
formulation. And then the next step is where we
decide what optimization algorithm is appropriate
for this kind of energy. So let's have a look. The
PDE is linear, and we use l2 squared around the
residual. So that makes this energy quadratic. So
it's a quadratic function on function space. And
as we all know, Newton's method for minimization
builds at every at where you add that your current
iterate, it builds a quadratic model of your
objective function, and it minimizes that
quadratic model. So Newton's method in function
space for this energy has one step convergence,
no matter where you start, and if I write out
Newton's method in function space, this is the
way it looks like. Here's the Fauci derivative
of our function space guy. This lives in the dual
space. Here is the Hessian. This is a bilinear
form. Or alternatively, it maps from the primal
to the dual space. This same thing, essentially.
And that's how it that's how it looks like. And if
your energy looks different, you would probably
choose something else that you will see an
example soon. And still no answers class this is
coming now. Now it's time to discretize. Now it's
time when you choose your answers. And I left the
ansatz generic. These, you could think of them as
neural networks, but you could also think of them
as finite element functions. Both is covered by
by the theory. Then the tension space is given
by the partial derivatives with respect to the
parameters of our access class and the objective,
the object that we're actually minimizing, which
is not no longer posted function space, but posted
parameter space. This L is the loss function,
and it's just pulling back our function space
energy, or parameter space, capital, theta. And
then we discretize Newton's methods. And what do
I mean by discretize? I mean we use this linear
space right, this tangent space. We use it to do a
Galerkin, a discretization of this by linear form,
right? This is just the second derivative
of e at U, theta, this current iterate.
This gives us a matrix G, and then we discretize
this guy here, too, in a Galerkin sense,
right? This comes from a dual space. This is
like your forcing in a finite element sense,
and this is nothing but the Euclidean gradient
of the loss. And then, if I then just freely
translate from Newton and function space to what
I just did with this Galerkin discretization,
I arrive at an optimization algorithm in parameter
space which is computable. Here I introduced also
a step size here. This is sort of the analogy of
the hessian matrix in this guy. Dagger denotes
a pseudo inverse, because I do not know whether
these guys are linearly dependent or not. Here's
the Euclidean gradient. So to make that explicit,
tying back to the example we had before, and this
was our energy, then this matrix G looks
like this, right? We have the form with the
laplacians coming from this term here, and we
have the boundary conditions coming from here.
And now it's time to implement and see how it
does. And it performs very well. So this what
I've just shown you. Is the is the green line
here, the problem is, again, a Poisson problem,
to be consistent with the explanation before. And
the formulation right was the pin formulation.
And maybe, if you've played around with physics
and formula networks, is sometimes quite hard to
optimize them. It's certainly very hard to get
acceptable or very high accuracies. And here we
see a relative l2 error. And of course, on a test
set of points, not on the ones we've trained on,
going down to 10 minus seven, sometimes we see
10 to the minus eight. And no other method that
we've tested and can come close. So why? Why
do I call that energy natural gradient descent?
That's because, when we first discovered this,
that you could actually. To optimize pins quite
well. We had a slightly different perspective.
We came from a natural gradient perspective,
and we thought about the Hessian as remaining
metric. And later, we realized that you can derive
this algorithm from this infinite dimensional
viewpoint that I've just shown you. And since this
was just one example, I tested it on on a bunch
of linear equations. Also we use the First Order
reformulation time dependent ones, and it works
really well for all of them. We do some tricks,
of course. I mean, we do a stabilization, living
black market kind of stabilization and so on. But
we can get very good accuracies with small
networks already for three dimensional PDE,
S and the training time is not horrible. Can
be seconds to minutes, depending on on your
setup and your GPU. So now to really drive that
idea home, that you can start from the from the
infinite dimensional viewpoint, I I want to show
a different example, which is a non linear PDE,
another stokes equation with where we will choose
a different algorithm on function space to begin
with, we'll choose Gauss Newton's algorithm and
function space. So if this is the PDE, and again,
we use a residual formulation. And for simplicity,
we ignore that. We should add a divergence penalty
and the boundary penalty here. Let's just look
at this. Then this is our formulation. And then
we can ask, okay, how should we optimize
that objective function in function space?
Then you see it's a non it is non linear inside
here, so it loses the convexity in function space
because of this non linearity. But it certainly
is a non linear least squares problem. And if
you want to solve non linear least squares
problem, a good choice is Gauss Newton's method,
or labeled markers method, and we do that
in function space. So it looks like this.
You have the linearization of the residual
after the adjoint. That's what you want to
in invert. And this is just for completeness,
the formula how this form sort of looks like
and you choose an ansatz, mu, theta, psi, for
velocity and pressure. The ansatz is again,
same notation as before. The tangent space is
again the linearization. And then you discretize
Gaussian UTZ algorithm, again, using a Galerkin
onsets. So you get back a matrix G and this is
your Euclidean gradient. This is how you get
the entries of the matrix. So you insert your
basis vectors from your Galerkin space that you
chose in the form. And again, you're left with
an optimization algorithm which, now in this
line, looks exactly as before. But of course,
this matrix G comes from a different, infinite
dimensional optimization algorithm. And again,
this works better than than any other optimizer
we could, we could find, and then we tried. This
is an unsteady 3d Beltrami flow. We could get
accuracy close to single precision. We couldn't
get 10 to the minus 10 as before, but it's still
better by a margin than than any everything else.
So to sort of come to a conclusion here is that
you can use this principle that I've showed you,
and you can start with different different
function space algorithms and to translate them,
and as a matter of fact, they often relate
to a known optimization method in parameter
space. Haven't shown you this before, but when I
introduce Newton, and if you do the computations,
you can find out what you actually doing in
parameter space. Is a generalized gauss Newton
method, or if you're solving a saddle point
problem. This is the La conch Newton method.
So you have a you have a constrained optimization
problem. You use la const formalism. You take,
you take the gradient of the lagoon, use
Newton's method to find the zeros of that
gradient. That's what I mean with La corn
Newton. And if you discretize that in the
way I've just shown you, you end up in certain
situations with competitive gradient descent,
which is proposed in a was proposed in a totally
different community, and gauss Newton function
space translates to gauss Newton. So I
think there's a lot to discover still.
And Marius, yes, there's a clarification
question. I think it's in slide 16. Robert
is asking, Is that G or inverse g
in the update? Oh, not 16 or 1515.
Here that the dagger is the pseudo inverse. Yeah,
you need, you need to invert the matrix. Yes,
is it clear or what? Okay, cool. Yeah. I'll talk
more about this matrix and how, how, uh, costly
that inversion is later on. Because I suppose
that's that's a very, very good question to have,
because, of course, there is some price that we
pay, but I'll talk about, I'll talk about that
soon. So I want to, because in the beginning I
promised that the methods that we derive will
provably mimic function space dynamics. So that's
what we're setting out to prove now, or to look at
when, when this is valid. So all the methods
that I've shown you before are of this form,
right? This guy is now, you said, right? We add a
direction. This is this direction, and I assume a
certain structure for this direction of a shade
derivative. And then you take it back to primal
space with the linear map with the inverse of a
linear map that might depend on your iterate. So
I assume this guy, T is linear, continuous,
at bijective. Everything we've seen before
falls into this setting. We also assume that this
map T is coercive, and if we assume that so the
technicalities of what we assumed for T are not so
critical, but if we assume that, then we can prove
the following, which I call the projection theory.
And let me walk you through this slide. So here is
just a repetition of to clarify the notation of
our generic optimization algorithm. And if within
parameter space we follow this algorithm right,
if we step, theta one, theta two, theta three,
and so on. Then we can ask ourselves, what is
happening on the function space level? What?
What do the functions do, and how do they relate
to stepping with the direction, DK? And you can
see here that actually we are stepping exactly
as the infinite dimensional algorithm. This is
the decay. But there is this pi guy with this,
which is a protection, and this is a Galerkin
projection on the tension space. And then there
is an error which corresponds to the step size
and the length of the step. So actually, this
is what I what I mean when I refer to provable
that we follow the functions based dynamics. And
let me give you a visual visualization of that,
of that theory, right? Let's just look at
the first at the first four images. This is,
again, Poissons equation, simple solution. You
essentially see the solution here, because your
theta, you should can. This is at initialization.
So this network is almost zero. So this direction
here is really the perfect update direction. If
you add this guy onto your current iterate, you'll
be at ground truth immediately. So all the other
update directions you want to match that picture,
and this is Newton and function space matches
perfectly, whereas Newton in parameter space,
which is a different algorithm, is clueless and
gradient descent too. And the same is repeated
here. Below this is a covad flow example. So
another stokes equation, where theta is now
somewhere somewhat close to the solution, say, the
order of a few percent of relative l2 error. So
again, this is the perfect update direction. And
if you look what gauss Newton and function space,
or Newton and function space tell you and what
they propose to step, or what they choose to step,
and it matches almost perfectly in the eyeball
mode, whereas Newton and parameter space or
gradient descent. Are not are not promising or not
good. We also see that in the the optimization. So
with that, let's get to scalability, because
so far, I've just shown you what works well,
and these algorithms work so well, you
get so high accuracy. But of course,
there is a price. And the price is that we
need to invert the matrix in every step,
and to go back to the to the managing natural
gradient, the Newton function space algorithm.
The Matrix you need to invert, to assemble, of
course, to invert, is the following one. And this
guy here. But if your answers is non local,
then this matrix is dense. It is typically
rank deficient and ill conditioned. So you have a
pretty a pretty challenging matrix to deal with.
Small scale, small networks are fine. You can
do an SVD, maybe, maybe because this matrix is
positive, semi definite, you regularized it a
little bit with a ticket of regularization, you
had an identity. You could use a Gillespie solve.
You'll be fine. But as soon as you scale up the
size of the networks, this is really challenging.
So what are our what are our options to scale it
up, you can use a matrix, free formulation that
works this system needs to be solved. You need
access to a matrix, vector products. You can get
them. The details are, for example, in this paper,
how to get the matrix vector products. You
just rely on that. You can reformulate it in
parameter space as a gauss Newton matrix, and
then you can do that. You can use CG, but CG
iterates for a long time because the matrix
is ill conditioned, but at least you can scale
up. A different strategy is to derive cheap
to invert approximations, and this is where
I'm going to focus on the rest of the talks. If
you take derivatives of linear network layers,
then you can find Chronica structure in that
matrix. And this chronicle structure can be
leveraged to build an approximation of g. And of
course, you can also aim to to combine these two,
these two strategies, you can build a GP inverter
approximation. You use it as a preconditioner in
your CG. So let's, let's get into the chronic
effect approximation. So very roughly, what
we want to do is we have that matrix G. You think
of your answers as a neural networks with layers.
This is what is one two, capital L corresponds to.
And you discard cross interaction between layers,
then you're left here with that with capital
L many matrices which are still quite big,
and then you aim to approximate them as chronicle
products of two smaller matrices. You approximate
them as chronic effects. Of course, because you
can, you can change the inverse with with the
factors, and this really gives you a dramatic,
a dramatic speed up in the solving so if you
say my my linear map, my linear layer and my
network maps from Rn to Rm, we're ignoring
biases here. Then this matrix, then the block
matrix up here is of size n times m squared,
but the Chronica factors are just n times n and
m times m. So you have, you have a drastic speed
up. You can scale up by a large margin. So how,
how do you get that chronic structure? I'll show
you that within with the with an example where
the Laplacian terms, so which is again motivated
from the Poisson which coming from the Poisson
equation. So what you can show is that the matrix
G, or the layer, that the block matrix correspond
to a layer, is of that form. So check this is the
Jacobian with respect to the L weight matrix.
Of this expression, transpose times itself.
And where you can find chronic structure is
if you take derivatives of this map, theta
now is a weight matrix and. The weight matrix
to weight matrix times fixed vector. And if
you take the Jacobian with respect to this matrix,
theta, then you'll get Chronica structure. Now if,
if you think about chain rule, what we need to
do to get out this, this chronic structure of
in our complicated computation graph is we need
to know what the children in the computational
graph of this map is. So the elf weight matrix
map to laplacian of u theta at a data point.
And I'm not going to go into the details, but what
how we could disentangle the structure is that
we relied on forward mode, or also called Taylor
mode, out to diff, which is also what is what was
recently proposed In the forward laplacian paper,
which is from the from the VMC community. So let's
just look at this graph. Think of a multi layer
perceptron, theta, are your chainable weights.
Just Just ignore biases. This is a weight matrix.
And we have L many this is your input. So going
through here just gives you your neural net
prediction. And of course, the weight matrix
enters as a matrix product to this vector. But of
course, we do not only want to forward to compute
the output of the neural network, but we also
want to compute first order derivatives and second
order derivatives, possibly more. But let's focus
on that so forward mode as in contrast to to back
propagation, you just push everything forward,
right? You multiply the matrices from the from
the other end. So this is what's happening here.
And when you do when you write out the recursion,
you see that the weight matrix doesn't only enter
into the forward propagation as a matrix product,
but it does also enter in the first derivatives
to integrate and also in the Laplacian So then,
if you factor this whole thing exactly as
the colors indicate, with pink and blue,
then you can leverage the chronic structure. And
I really do not want to go into detail here, but
this viewpoint lets us compute exactly how that
matrix looks. It looks horrible, three sums, a
lot of symbols, Chronica structure here. So I note
this is not an approximation. This really is an
equality. And then the cafe approximation, which
is hand wave, which is hand waving, admittedly,
but is put into great use in the deep learning
community, is to swap the sum and the chronicler,
and we also hear drop indices that are different
from each other. So we really end up with an
approximation as exactly as I promised to you.
So the matrix G can be approximated as a Chronica
B. So this was the outline. It's technical. You
can find the details in our in our recent paper,
which is going to be in Europe's and i've showed
it to you for the Poisson problem. But it does
actually work for general non linear PDS. With the
pin formulation, you could do it for very rational
formulations with the Brits method. We haven't
looked into neural operators. This requires more
work, so there we uncertain how it, how it
would play out. And typically, once you have
this approximation for G, there's a whole bunch
of bells and whistles you put on top of on top of
your optimizer would be a trust region method for
step size choice. You would do exponential moving
average for the case matrices, you would maybe
update them infrequently. So so there are many,
many things you can do. And I said, you find, you
find the details. It's not the pre print at this
point anymore. In in this paper here, and
then I want to show you some experiments,
just to illustrate that, that we we keep the
good performance, or we can reproduce the
good performance in the small experiments, but we
can scale to big networks. So to warm up, here's
again, the. Saw equation. The blue lines are the
methods that do not scale right, that that require
a dense matrix that you need to invert. The black
lines are K fac. The light green line is the CG
version of the natural gradient. And then we have,
first all the methods in red and orange and lbfgs
in dark green. And what you see here in the small
example, this is always relative l2 error over
time. The naive way of doing things is actually
the best one. Whereas as soon as you scale up,
this is the dimension. These are the number of
trainable weights in your neural network. Then
at some point you cannot do the naive approach
anymore, but the black lines always are among the
best performing. So now we move up in dimension.
We do a heat equation in four spatial and one time
dimension, and the picture is similar. And
finally, we've we, we went up to 1 million
parameters with a 100 deep soul equation.
Actually, I believe this experiment is still
running here. We did a patient search for the
hyper parameters. So there's a lot of lot of work
that goes on into these numerical experiments,
and to really fine tune these optimizers before,
before then after finding good hyper parameters,
they're really ready to use. So this is by no
means the end of the of the of the sort of journey
for really making the best out of this optimizer,
and then just put it in context, or put this cafe
in context. This approximation allows us to scale
millions of parameters that works really
well. Our I still call them preliminary,
somewhat preliminary, numerical experience. They
compare favorably to all established optimizers,
often outperforming them, and you can do the
approximation I've showed you virtually to any
PDE, but it will be interesting to see more
equation we are working on that right now.
And of course, maybe this is the main point.
The cafe approximation is not so easy to set up,
so you need a dedication to implement that and
to make it run. And with that, I just want to
wrap up and maybe give an outlook I think of what,
what I what can be done next in sort of that area,
and where I think future work is. Future efforts
are well, well placed. So I think the function
space viewpoint is far from exploited. I think
there's still many things one can do. There's many
concepts you can still translate among them,
for example, trust region methods, infinite
dimensional ones, or operator preconditioning
approaches. I'm also not aware of any convergence
theory that really properly separates the
function space and the parameter space. And
I think there's still a lot to do on the case
side on, just improving the optimizer we've
built, we haven't really tried to use it as a
precondition. And matrix free implementations
currently working on a high dimensional PDE
is like Fokker, Planck, Hamiltonian, Jacobi,
Belmont equation, Schrodinger equations. I
think there is a lot to come. And with that,
I want to thank you for your attention and
happy to take questions. Awesome. Thank
you so much for the wonderful talk.
Very nice, very nice. So let's
Yeah, yeah. May I maybe exit full screen mode so
that I see you if somebody is asking questions, or
maybe that's not a good idea, I leave it open so
that we can go back to slides for the questions.
Yeah, the people can unmute themselves
and then ask questions directly and yes,
let's have a Q and A sessions. I can start, I
guess so for more general, non linear problems,
you use switch from the Newton to gauss
Newton. See, because, you know, to avoid,
you know, the computing the full hessian
informations, because that sum up. I can,
I can tell you why we do, why we do that. So when
the when the objective is non convex, of course,
you have no guarantee that your you. Newton matrix
is definite, right? It could be indefinite. And
then you have no guarantee that the what
you step is actually a descent direction,
only if you get close to to the minimizer,
then you know that Newton's matrix will
get definite. And when we do the numerical
experiments, and we observe precisely that,
if we knew use Newton in function space right, and
discretize it that way and and step, then it's not
stable. It doesn't go in the right direction. But
if you're close to the minimum and use Newton,
then it is very close to gauss Newton at function
space, which is also too expected to be expected.
And we found gauss Newton just to be the more
robust choice, because you always, because
you linearize, you always have the guarantee
that you taking a decent direction. Cool. Very
nice, not just for, you know,
avoid the avoiding the implementation
comparison, but it does actually,
yeah, I mean, because you compute the
second the Newton matrix, right, the
infinite dimensional object is always something
that you compute with pen and paper. So there is,
there is maybe a little bit. It's maybe
a little bit more difficult to compute
with on pen and paper the Newton matrix
than to compute the gauss Newton matrix,
but it's comparable, and implementation is maybe
an epsilon more difficult for the Newton matrix,
but you can do both, but the performance of the
Gaussian is just more stable. Okay, wonderful.
All right. Stephanie, do you want to
unmute yourself and ask questions?
Thanks for the talk. I was wondering if
you can comment more on the connection to
the natural gradient and Riemann manifold
you mentioned. That's the angle you came
from at the beginning. Did you divert
from that, or is it still the same
so many of the methods I've shown you, maybe I
go back to a slide where I can easily explain
that can be interpreted as maybe that's actually
a good slide. Yeah, that's a good slide. So many
of the methods can be interpreted as a natural
gradient method, and they can be interpreted
as a natural gradient method precisely when
this T map here, right? This guy is symmetric,
right? If this object really here is an inner
product of function space, then actually you're
doing a natural gradient method, or a Romanian,
right? A Romanian gradient descent method. But
there is no need for T to be symmetric.
If, if you look at saddle point problems,
and there was this example of La cons Newton and
competitive gradient descent, then this T is not,
is not right. And then the method you get is not
a natural gradient method is not the remaining
metric that you're using to design, sort of your
pre condition for your gradient. So we switch to
functions based viewpoint because it's, it's more
general, but everything with the natural gradient
descent is still valid, is still a good viewpoint?
Does that answer your question? Yes, it does.
I'm might have some follow up
questions later on. I think I
want to digest that a little bit,
but I might shoot you an email, if
that's okay. Yeah, I'm happy
to take emails, of course.
Awesome. Great. Any other questions? While someone
has a question, I have another question. So if you
go to slide 22 Yes, the size of the matrix is
proportional to the size of the answers. Yes,
exactly, exactly the dimensionality
of your parameter space. And I'm
guessing that's the performance
of this great gradient descent
will depends on the size of the onset
as well. I mean, more the better. I
guess. Say that what will
depend on the answers as well
the performance, like the
convergence behavior of this. Oh,
yeah. So I mean, if, if your answers is
more expressive than sort of you you expect,
right? It's richer you can, you can, you can do
better, it will always depend on on your specific
problem, right? So then you need bigger answers.
Sometimes the smaller sufficient. Oh, okay, so,
so I see the the balancing game here. So you need
more answers, but if you increase the answers,
then your matrix becomes bigger and bigger,
and you're dealing with the. Science matrix,
so it's harder to solve numerically, and
so they're just there. There must be some
sweet spot between those two balancing game. If
you can comment on that from your experience,
yeah, so I can say something. I don't know if
this will be a perfect answer, but if you're
looking into you know simpler problems where
maybe your solution is not highly oscillatory,
but it's okay, somewhat smooth, not too
complicated. Then we found that you can
actually use relatively small networks like
the default would probably write. You set ups,
you set something up in checks or pytorch, and you
just go big, because the frameworks will do it,
and your GPU can do it. But often it might not
even be needed. And then it's, of course, easier
to to get it to run if you, if you reduce the size
a bit, and these algorithms play nicely with that,
with Adam sometimes, or with first stochastic,
first order methods sometimes you you,
you have the feeling you need to go big with
to make it work, okay. But these also work.
Work quite well in a smaller network and a
smaller in a smaller regime. But of course,
if your if your function is complicated,
if you're solving a many electron schroding
equation, there is no way you can use a small
network. And I think then there is no way around
using some approximation of these methods. I
mean, as a matter of fact, this, this K fac,
is, I think, the gold standard for neural network
based many electron Schrodinger equations. In this
community. They do not use PD PDE operators in
in the preconditioner, they use sort of an l2
based version of that. But they found this
to be crucial to optimize wave functions.
Okay, my next question is about the
Chronicle, you know k factor. You
call it k factor, yes, yeah,
that's a approximate of the Jacobian,
the way of computing. So it's,
yeah, exactly. So there's two approximations
that we're doing. There's this matrix G, we do
a block diagonal approximation of that matrix,
and then the diagonal blocks, you approximate
them as Chronica products. So it's, it's, it's
a very aggressive approximation of g, yes, okay.
And I'm wondering if it can be, since it is
approximate, it can be used as a preconditioner. I
think it, I think it can, and
it's relatively high on our
to do list to actually try that. Okay. Oh, yeah,
any other question from audience, you can
unmute yourself and then ask questions.
Well, if not, let's thank our speaker today. Thank
you so much in Europe right now.
How? What time is it? There? It's,
it's 10 to 10 to seven. Oh,
10 to seven. Oh, okay, not that bad. I
hope you. No, no, not, not bad at all.
But I happens to know that Marius has a two kids
and very young, four years old and six months and
they need to go to bed now. Yes, they'll
require my help. They require your help,
but thank you so much for having me in this
wonderful seminar. Thank you so much. Yeah, well,
my last question would be before we head off log
logo here, obviously, you know the national lab,
they deal with the very, very large scale
problems, and also the complexity is, is the multi
physics and multi fidelity, that's sort of the
problem. So, you know, the it's still questionable
your method is how it is applicable to directly
to those complex problems. I'm sure there's a
way to go. I mean, it's more research and more
development is required. So I'm, I will do my you
know, best of you know how we can collaborate or
bring this you know idea to the multi physics end,
yes, if you are interested, if you have a high
think these neural network based methods for PDS,
are you. Especially interesting for high
dimensional PDE s or maybe potentially high
dimensional parameter spaces, if it's if you
have a realistic problem, yeah, feel free to
reach out. We're currently working on a on an easy
to use pied watch, implementation of the of the
capac method that I've shown you. So please let me
know if you're interested in trying something out.
Please reach out. Okay, well, we'll do Wow.
Thank you so much for the wonderful talk,
Marius. And let's thank let's
applause to our great speaker today,
and that was very nice, and we
learned a lot from you, Maria. So
we appreciate it so much. Bye,
thank you. Bye, bye.